is anyone else sick to death of politics
well every politician out there claims
that they work for their constituents
it's become increasingly clear over the
years that all they really care about is
enriching themselves and making even
more money for the giant Shady
corporations who fund their campaigns
and with people understandably becoming
increasingly disenchanted with the
endless bickering and division of the
two-party system people wish they had an
alternative rather than a politician who
claims to be a good person but is
actually secretly evil What If instead
we elected an entity that we all knew
was evil from the beginning that's why
today we're hitting the anomalous
campaign Trail seeing what an utter
disaster the world seems to have been
lately a number of the SCP foundation's
most bizarre anomalies have decided that
they could do as good a job as anyone
else running for office right now so
let's hear them out see what their
campaign promises are and what Fringe
new parties they're representing so we
want to hear from you the view viewers
on which anomaly has secured your vote
and why and with that let's put on our
political correspondent hat and get knee
deep into the dirty horrific world of
these potential super creepy Presidents
or scps first of all we have the most
experienced political operative at the
SCP Foundation Dr Jack Bright
representing the come on you've had
worse party unlike all the other
anomalies on this list if you elect Dr
bright this will technically be his
second term in office given that he
controlled the body of former President
George W bush throughout his eight-year
presidential term so if you're willing
to overlook the whole Iraq war thing
he's got that killer experience and hey
for the kind of person who wants an
Everyman president then Dr bright is the
ideal candidate for you seeing as he's
literally occupied the body of every
type of man woman child and some animals
no matter who you are Dr bright can
relate to your plight but maybe despite
his experience Dr bright still seems
like too much of a young Buck to be the
leader of the Free World you want
someone sagely and experienced and you
don't want to break the streak of having
all world leaders be tapioca munching
senior citizens may we introduce you to
scp-106 of the pocket Dimension party
he's an older gentleman sure but it's
given him wisdom that youth could never
replace at least in terms of knowing how
to torture people with terrifying
efficacy he's also a veteran having
fought and sustained injuries in the
trenches of world war one so he's got
the interest of the nation's disaffected
veterans in mind he's also committed to
transparency and breaking down
boundaries or at least walking directly
through them the biggest downside of
having scp-106 as president is the fact
that he's a little forgetful in his old
age and also every month he demands 14
life sacrifices from the U.S citizenry
because well the job is stressful he
needs to blow off steam and he just
can't stand playing golf but hey maybe
like a lot of people out there are your
biggest concern on the ballot is Health
Care you want to know that your
pre-existing conditions will be covered
and that if you end up getting sick your
treatment will be both effective and
affordable you also want to guarantee
quick responses to emerging viral
threats like say a pestilence that's why
you might want to cast your vote for
scp-049 the plague doctor from the end
the pestilence party sure this charming
French gentleman may have not been born
in the U.S but some rules are worth
bending for the sake of the greater good
the plague doctor wants to ensure that
the nation and the world are healthy and
happy no matter how many people he needs
to kill and turn into zombies to do it
he's also polite intelligent and
dignified for those who want to add a
nice little touch of European class to
the Oval Office but perhaps you're not
in it for The Superficial qualities
maybe you want a president whose every
action comes from a deep well of empathy
and a desire to make other people happy
if this sounds like it reflects your
personal opinion and beliefs then it's
time to cast your vote for scp-99 the
Tickle Monster from the cuddles for
everyone party 999 runs on a strict
anti-war platform instead hoping to
spread love and care among the nation's
citizens and make the desire to uplift
others part of everyone's sense of civic
duty scp-999 also has big plans for
investing in Mental Health Services
owing to his own long history working in
the field with a particular view towards
treating people suffering from
depression and PTSD then again maybe all
this talk of love and flower power has
you rolling your eyes maybe you're
someone who fundamentally has contempt
for the human race and wants to vote for
any candidate who's eager to speedrun us
to complete and utter destruction cause
hey we had our chance and we fumbled the
ball if you agree with this a you're
pretty scary please stay away from us
and B you're going to love
scp-682 the hard to destroy reptile the
front runner of the complete omnicide
party his campaign promises include
reinstating the national death penalty
and making breathing a capital offense
poisoning the water supply and launching
all the nukes at once turning the
surface of the Earth into lifeless blown
glass hey at least he's honest we can
give him that much maybe you don't want
to destroy the human race out of sheer
unending hatred but you are sick of what
a circus politics has become it's a
reality show these days politicians
aren't here to fight for your rights and
privileges they're here to fight for air
time but this isn't the case with our
next Presidential hopeful
scp-096 the shy guy from the oh God
please don't look at me you doom fools
party he's not a camera hog in fact
he'll literally annihilate anyone who
looks at him you'll find him
thoughtfully pacing back and forth in
the Oval Office muttering to himself
like Abraham Lincoln or Nixon his aides
will get most of the work done because
he'll be too busy sobbing relatable
right
we have fun here so this next candidate
isn't actually an anomaly but he did
threaten to break my legs if I didn't
let him join in so um please we present
to you presidential hopeful Dr alto clef
of the shoot first ask questions later
party being an ex-member of the global
occult Coalition clef has experience
with bureaucracy and being a government
Insider even though his method of
interacting with these systems is
typically extreme gung-ho violence one
of cleft's major platforms is gun
control as in when he's in control
everyone is going to have so many guns
so if you yearn for the days of the wild
wild west then you ought to give alto
clef your vote please don't though we're
afraid of what he'll do with more power
okay so if none of the rest of these
candidates has impressed you so far how
about a Trailblazer a president that
represents progress not only the first
female president but the first Hindu
president and believe it or not she's
actually testing extremely well with men
it says cp029 the daughter of Shadows of
the Neil before me party she's got a
long history in leadership with her
generations of Thug cultists all of whom
are slavishly devoted to her they make
K-pop stands look positively fair
weather in comparison all her main
policies involve worshiping her and to
be sure to avoid her most devoted
followers at the polls if you plan on
not voting for her they might fly into a
blind rage and strangle you well that
all got a little scary and violent
didn't it let's move away from that and
instead think about the nation's youth
for a moment children are the future and
nobody understands children and their
needs better than Dr wondertainment head
of the lovely toys for girls and boys
party Dr wondertainment is a figure of
joy and Whimsy and under President
wondertainment the country would have
become more amusingly wacky than ever
thanks to every child being guaranteed
some of his marvelous anomalous toys but
he's not all fun in games Dr
wondertainment is also a businessman
with a long track record of success
despite being regularly attacked by the
SCP Foundation so you know under his
presidency the needs of small businesses
would be understood and taken care of
but to become president you need votes
and to win votes you need hearts and
Minds Sometimes the best way to do this
is to cultivate a core voting block of
completely devoted high energy voters
like say furries that's why we think
scp-1471 Mao o of the cursed internet
history party has what it takes to
battle their way to the top we really
don't know much what Mal o wants to do
specifically save for loosening cyber
security standards so everyone can
download its cursed app but really does
a potential president really need
policies and ideals is it not enough
that they just make you feel good
sometimes it's all just about Vibes and
I think that's the bravest political
stance to take of all vote Mal o for a
deviantART future uh okay okay I think
we went a little too far there but it's
part of a wider cultural Trend it seems
today that all you see is violence in
movies and sex on TV but where are those
good old-fashioned values on which we
used to rely luckily there's
scp-1867 Lord Blackwood for the British
Imperial party to help set us all back
on track he's an old-fashioned guy from
a bygone era where women were women and
men were telepathic sea slugs think of
him as a modern day Teddy Roosevelt a
renaissance man skilled in Warfare
business adventuring and hunting he's
sure to win over voters with his
trademark folksy charm and his ability
to spin captivating Yarns is likely to
help him crush it at debates and Town
Hall meetings but that's nothing
compared to the kinds of votes you can
get when you're able to literally
control people's minds with terrifying
psychic abilities this is the primary
advantage of scp-035 the possessive mask
representing the Mind melting Arcane
Secrets party
scp-035 has access to knowledge so
terrifying that even hearing it would
cause you to be plunged into a state of
utterly irrevocable Madness and he's
also a very persuasive speaker if you
attend one of his speeches you'll hear
his words slithering into your mind
slowly rearranging your thoughts like
chess pieces on a board until you're
hanging off his every word the one
downside of his regime would be that
he'll need a revolving door of Vice
Presidents whose bodies he would steal
and melt one by one sometimes to get
what you want you need to make
compromises folks okay before we get too
deep into this anomalous Rabbit Hole
let's lean back out for a second and
consider another SCP Foundation Insider
someone calm someone measured someone as
boring as muesli falling in a bowl full
of off-white paint but reliable as a
tough old mule we are of course talking
about Dr Charles Ogden Gears of the
doesn't like attending parties party
look we know he doesn't play great for
the camera but sometimes all you need is
someone who's got the personality of a
piece of drywall with a complex math
equation written on it will simply forge
on and get the job done that's what you
can expect from Dr gears he'll simply
get the job done no bells or whistles
our next candidate on the other hand
loves Bells sleigh bells specifically
and that sleigh spelled s-l-a-y that's
right it's
scp-466 the Yule man of the Christmas
party he also wants to bring back
Traditional Values specifically the
values of pure mortal Terror
traditionally experienced by our ancient
ancestors while fleeing from primordial
Predators he will ensure that Christmas
is celebrated even if his methods of
Christmas celebration are a little well
let's say severe he'll also introduce a
number of policies to fight climate
change making sure it's always nice and
cold during the winter after all where's
the fun in standing outside someone's
bedroom window on Christmas Eve if there
isn't nice crunchy snow underfoot maybe
you don't care about Christmas though
maybe you just want a potential
president that's young and hungry and I
mean really hungry we're talking about
scp-082 Ferdinand the cannibal of the
Donner Party and honestly he might be
the most qualified presidential
candidate of anyone on this list
according to a written note that he sent
us he's actually been the president four
times already he's also got six
different phds and various subjects from
Harvard Stanford and Cornell University
in addition to two Nobel prizes a
Pulitzer prize-winning series of novels
and an oscar-winning screenplay based on
his life as the first man on the moon
he's also apparently had a plan on how
to simultaneously end overpopulation and
hunger but he's been a little cagey
about the specifics but let's be real
here two of the most important qualities
of a presidential candidate are Clarity
and transparency and that's exactly what
scp-055 the ante meme of the
non-pherical party promises to offer
it's
um uh you know damn it it's on the tip
of my tongue okay it's gone what were we
talking about again oh yeah anomalous
presidents
move on to the next one and see what
he's all about the next candidate has a
claim to the childhoods of millions he's
one of the world's most successful and
acclaimed businessmen and is probably
one of the most famous Americans
worldwide it's the cryogenically frozen
head of Walt Disney also known as
scp-2805 Disney on Ice of the corporate
consolidation party but it's not just
name recognition that this beloved
beheaded businessman boasts it's also
lots and lots of money which is valuable
for someone campaigning for the
presidency and considering the fact that
Disney seems to be rapidly acquiring and
owning everything I guess it makes sense
in the long term that he'd also end up
owning America too but maybe you want a
president with a better head on their
shoulders or at least a president whose
head is actually attached to their
shoulders you also want a president who
is just a solid guy solid as a rock or
perhaps concrete and rebar and Krylon
brand spray paint we're talking of
course of SCP-173 of the Weeping Angel
party with some politicians you get the
sense that they're only going to do your
job when the public is watching them
like a hawk the second we look away they
slump back in their chairs and grab the
paddle ball
SCP-173 is literally the opposite he
does all his best work while nobody else
is watching he's no talk all action and
you have to appreciate that kind of
dedication in this day and age when the
serious sculpture is President politics
is a real snap perhaps you're of the
opinion that the U.S needs to take a
more hawkish approach to International
Affairs you miss the days of constant
Global Wars and fighting you're the kind
of person who listens to Senator
Armstrong ranting in Metal Gear Rising
Revengeance and thinks hey this guy
actually has some pretty good ideas then
you're going to love the idea of our
next prospective president
scp-076-2 Abel from the might makes
right party Abel is really just about
one thing and one thing only fighting
when he does inevitably lead the country
into a cataclysmic War he'll be the
first president since Washington to
charge in at the very front of the army
a pair of ebony swords drawn and ready
to taste blood and if he dies on the job
all we need to do is wait for him to
rise from his black sarcophagus for his
term to resume how wonderful but hey
maybe after all of this you're
completely disenchanted with the U.S
political system you're tired of
presidents of Congress of democracy of
the whole complicated mess you want to
return to a simpler age an age of
unilateral decisions made by a single
all-powerful ruler pure monarchism is
what we're saying and who's a more eager
Monarch than the Scarlet King this
interdimensional nightmare has killed
more Gods than there are grains of sand
on your nearest beach so there's
probably no problem on Earth he can't
solve if he puts his diabolical mind to
it a major downside of being under the
Scarlet King's rule is that there would
be a lifetime appointment for him and
the Scarlet King has an infinite
lifespan Notions like Freedom hope and
joy will have to go out the window and
instead be replaced with the classic
concepts of Terror rage and horrendous
Primal violence with the Scarlet King in
charge he's also likely to reinstall the
long-lost devite culture some of his
most Ardent worshipers so expect to
learn a whole lot about different and
interesting civilizations if the Scarlet
King is able to get his iron clutches on
our reality what nobody ever said
playing politics was nice folks and
there you have it our anomalous
presidential nominees straight from the
SCP Foundation which one of these would
you vote for are there any nominations
we missed let us know down in the
comments and remember whoever wins we
lose well except 999 that'd be a pretty
sweet deal now go check out Dr bright
for President scp-444 Bush vs Gore and
scp-001 the Scarlet King for more on
your future leaders